foreign
[Music]
yeah it was fun I mean it's like
legitimately the the first like I don't
know like real legit event we've been to
like that there was a Spotify party that
we went to or whatever you but it wasn't
yeah it was not as official as that it
wasn't as like security everywhere and
uh like we had to go through like bomb
dogs to get to the red carpet bomb dogs
or for like gun dogs or whatever they're
sniffing for I don't know what do you
think it is it's not drugs right it's
like weapons and [ __ ] yeah no yeah the
bomb dog had to sniff us out maybe that
was like Taylor Swift's or something
no I think aren't those for smelling
drugs
but like who would bring drugs into like
I think it's more for people's safety
like no one's like smuggling drugs into
a right like what do they want to sell
it there dude bringing like just 10 10
[ __ ] keys of cocaine to the amas
just standing
like in the aisle being like yo you want
Coke people walking by here you go no no
cool
front rows TV Stevie Wonder's performing
Stevie yeah yeah you want to take it up
a notch yeah yo Steve you party
Stevie I know you can't see me bro but
you can hear this yeah everyone's like
who's to do with the backpack in here
I'd get a backpack
yeah bro yo Coqui Molly
Molly Molly yeah you ever heard that
it's been forever since I've heard that
dude we like we like did this one New
Year's and we just like walked down
South Beach and like that's all we heard
cook me Molly Ooey Molly Coco Molly yeah
those invites from strangers and those
like party areas are it's like a haunted
house yeah they like always kind of come
out of like some dark area yeah just say
that [ __ ] as they're coming at you ah it
almost feels like animatronic like they
just pop out of the darkness like okay
like a cuckoo clock
weed Molly
call Queen Molly Molly
hello you know what I love when when the
dude has kind of like low confidence
like you maybe make eye contact
beforehand yeah maybe too much like you
make eye contact two or three times
prior then you get close to him he's
like
y'all trying to smoke
maybe
no no no no no I'm not trying to yeah I
know yeah I'll just play no it's just I
was just I don't know I'm just out here
yeah bye guys yeah lighter but let me
know though if you want to damn now I'm
just thinking about drug dealers but
it's they're having the same
conversation that Best Buy managers have
with new employees what
like
the guy comes back and then
the Dealer's like okay
that was it was decent contact remember
when you make contact with a customer
you want to be confident you can
establish it yeah but what what What's
the phrase
they have like some [ __ ] catchphrase
like
we want to make sure we're using the
thanks system you know
thank them first thank them for their
time and then initiate the cell yeah and
then initiate the sale of cocaine cut
with fentanyl yeah
damn customer service has drug dealers
sorry I'm just still going on this
you're walking by hey thanks so much for
coming down to South Beach brings you
guys down this week
I don't know man I'm just hanging out as
vacation I guess cool cool cool just
looking for a Vibe yeah yeah exactly
just trying to catch a Vibe yeah all
right man
oh well before you go oh we got a couple
vibes okay I could maybe interest you in
sure I mean uh we got Coke weed Molly
what's your thing okay
oh we're not interested are you sure are
you sure yeah I mean sure there's plenty
of bars on here but not many guys like
me it sounds great man but we gotta
listen listen listen we got a
reservation so let me let me tell you
let me tell you a little something about
these drinks let me tell you a little
something about these drinks okay you've
heard of wild drinks yes okay well these
are well well drinks okay okay how much
are you gonna spend on alcohol tonight
50 bucks maybe try again buddy oh more
do you think if you
tell me that all right I'm sold Give me
the give me the fentanyl now this fennel
does come with a protection plan
for seven extra dollars we you can uh
get a [ __ ] stick a narcot oh Jesus
you do have to bring the body back here
though all right sorry
I was just thinking of all the Best Buy
[ __ ] that they say
damn what are the features
of of the coke weed Molly yeah well it
depends okay okay it depends what you go
with
um you're going with all three what do
you think you want let's do all three
yeah is that like the
is that like the premium package yes
okay yeah and what are the that'd be all
three
so uh it's pretty simple uh we don't
advise that you do Coke and Molly in the
same stint okay we sort of advise
um our rule is uh two is cool three is
Ooey
two is called threes away yes that's
easy to remember yeah okay that's who's
cool three is Ooey yeah okay sorry I
don't know much about Coakley Molly by
the way my my son is a big you know he's
all into it oh yeah they're younger you
know they get it I know they get it so
but I me I'm a total Noob when it comes
to this stuff so that's it that's okay
this is a term my son uses that's okay
so I don't really know much about uh we
we have a young lady by the name of
Destiny uh she hangs out here on the
corner sometimes but she would love to
show you just a little lap around Coke
weed Molly okay we can bundle her into
the price it sure and she'll hang out
for the night okay she'll tour you
around Molly no problem okay yeah
so yeah the features are I'm gonna get
super [ __ ] up you're gonna ruin your
family but
what else you're in South Beach for bud
what this is a quick question yeah if I
like if I like it do I have to uh like
come back and buy the buy the cartridges
oh no the the the koku mall is
dispensable right so I can come back and
and re-up and yeah suspenseful in a way
okay we can set you up on a subscription
service okay sure yeah that's it sounds
great yeah yeah is there Apple Care
like I said uh as long as you bring the
body here within 30 days of it dying
we'll do our best okay that was a great
deal yeah no no replacement plan though
sorry it went too long
it's not too long with that